[Music]
I was listening to your show a couple
months ago on the podcast and uh I heard
a couple qualities of the jerk husband
and a few of them rang the cord with me
and uh need some help man bro that's a
big step for you to say hey that's me
and I don't want to be like this anymore
good for you man you got my you got my
mad respect on that
[Music]
man woo what's up up this is John with
the Dr John deloney show a show about
your
marriage whoever it is you're trying to
date your kids being a good dad being a
good mom your mental emotional health
whatever you got going on in your life
on this show uh we take calls from
people all over planet Earth who are
trying to figure out what's going on in
their life how they can get out of a
messy situation what they can do next to
better love their families um to be
better husbands be better wives whatever
you got going on in your life the show
is about real people going through real
stuff if you want to be on I'd love to
have you on give me a buzz at
33291 1844 693 3291 or go to John
dooney.com
ask and um it makes all the difference
in the world when you hit the Subscribe
button on the YouTube channel if you hit
the Subscribe button wherever it is you
consume podcast um it's just been
astounding to me the growth this last
year in the show people are coming from
all over the place I'm so grateful to
have everybody here um and if you will
hit that subscribe button it makes all
the difference in the world it dumps the
show into the algorithms and it puts it
in front of other people who are just
simply at the end of the rope and they
reach for a computer or for their phone
and they just type
in how do I be a better dad how be a
better husband or what happening with my
what's happening with me and my wife and
then this show gets dropped into their
algorithm because you hit subscribe
something that simple and cost anything
didn't take much time so thank you so so
much for doing that all right let's
reach out to Todd in Salt Lake City
what's up
Todd not much how are you we're partying
dude what's up I'm just working um okay
my question I was listening to your show
a couple months ago on the podcast and
uh I heard a couple qualities of the
jerk husband and a few of them rang the
chord with me and uh need some help man
I I almost think you you instantly opt
out of jerk well I won't say you
automatically opt out but bro that's a
big step for you to say hey that's me
and I don't want to be like this anymore
good for you man you got my you got my
mad respect on that man so uh what are
you working
through um you know I just one of the
characterists I stood out and I've told
my wife that she takes the victimhood
route sometimes and so that definitely
strung a chord just still a lot of
distance between us more of than not and
it's me um I'm guarded I have my
barriers up and just can't quite figure
out why good what's I mean dude that's
you are at the starting line man
congratulations um how long have you
been married 18 years 18 years you got
kids four kids tell me about your
wife um
she's you know good Mom good wife she
just uh she's been primarily a
stay-at-home wife for a long time um
just kind of getting back into the the
Working World and um so she's taken that
on and how long have you how long have
you protected yourself from
her a long time dude probably like I
would say 10 years 12 years what kicked
that
off I think it came off when she like
when she found out I was watching
pornography back a long time ago and the
way she reacted to that and the lot of
ter the social turmoil and things that
happened M um with that okay a lot of
Shame embarrassment you know she felt
inadequate all those things and then you
ended up with a lot of Shame and
embarrassment and you felt
inadequate and you kind of just built
your own house on either side of the of
the river there huh yeah 100%
okay um what was
um I'm from a uh I guess you call it a
new camp if you will
um where I'll call them vices for lack
of better terms just the easiest way to
describe them but things that we do um
that we know in the long term aren't
good for us they're going to kill us in
some shape form or fashion but in the
short-term work they
help and um it might sound crazy but I
classify pornography in that in that
boat it works in a very very short term
and then it kind of destroys everything
over time um what was pornography
getting you at the time cuz my here's my
guess is my guess is it got called out
with that one particular thing but my
guess is the separation was way before
that even yeah you're right probably um
I would say like what did it get me it
got me like decompression right like
stress release I was going through
school at the time um pretty newly
married um a kid on the way uh so there
was a lot going on and you know
traditionally I didn't think of myself
as a smart person so School has always
been a challenge for me so there's a lot
of stress and it was kind of a high
stakes program so a lot of stress and
anxiety and it's something I've been
doing since I was young to kind of deal
with emotional stuff sure I want to go
beneath the Stress and Anxiety though
because it does like you know
pornography alcohol like all that stuff
like certain drugs they they work as a
Xanax right actually Xanax works as a
Xanax right it works but you said
something underneath that that's really
important um you were in a very tough
academic program and you've never been a
smart guy insert story here uhhuh you're
a guy who works really hard and you like
to have answers for your
friends and now you got a kid on the
way you I'm gonna I love this woman I
love my girlfriend we're gonna have this
fun marriage we're going to have sex all
the time now you're about to be a dad
and you've never been married to a
pregnant woman and I don't know how to
do this either so there's that less than
less than less than shame I should know
and I don't know and I don't know and I
don't know I'm just going to go to this
one and I love how you said it stress
release because most people think they
go to it for x or for y or for Z many
many millions of people go to it as a
way to distract himself from a life they
don't
like or a life that here's a better I
don't know how to
do yeah
um so then you Foster that and you just
pour gasoline on it for 10 years or 20
years right and now you're here almost
on knock on the door two decades of
being
married and is that phrase uh you sit by
each other on the couch you're 6 Ines
apart but 6,000 mies away from each
other a lot of times yeah yeah
mhm so you want to you want to make your
way back or is this is this when you
call it because a lot of people get this
far and they're like dude we had a good
run we raised good kids we we held
together a good household for the back
half of our life let's split up and
let's ride or die with somebody that's
just going to be wheels
off no man it's worth working back to
yeah for sure okay so
um we don't have a ton of time together
I'd love man I'd love to to talk to you
and your wife sometime what can I help
you with today what are you thinking
about that you want to work through that
you want to think about doing
differently uh I just I want to to work
my way back or just learn how to lower
my walls you know um get those defensive
defenses down that are primarily on my
side of the the river so to speak okay
so I think there's two things to play at
play here number one y'all both
y'all can't move into one another's
house on either side of the
river youall have to both leave the
house you're in and decide together
we're going to build a new
one that okay okay so you have to think
of it this way the marriage up until now
18 years has gotten you here we're going
to decide to build a new marriage and in
this new marriage I am going to be this
this is what I need in this in this new
marriage
season and I want you to not think cuz I
can hear it in your voice bro you're not
broken there's nothing wrong with you
yeah okay
um your body has a very keen
understanding of what happens when you
get embarrassed in front of your
wife she nukes
you and your body knows okay
cool we hide that's where we
go and your body got a bunch of uh
cinder blocks start building some walls
and that way nobody's getting inside the
innert and it actually keeps the peace
right yeah it also keeps all the good
stuff out
too yeah right and so the only way
through it I wish there was another way
bro the only way through it is to bite
down on your mouthpiece and head
directly through it and that's to sit
down with your wife and say
um in a in an effort to protect myself
from getting embarrassed or feeling
ashamed I walled off and I forced you to
chase me
and live off gulps of air for the last
20 years and I'm not doing that
anymore and I want to be fully present
with you and I want to be vulnerable I
want us to be open I want to build a new
kind of
marriage and I don't know how to do that
and by the way it's going to feel weird
is all crap to her
too she in intellectually she wants
something different she's been trying to
get it for so long but often when
somebody just starts being vulnerable
their partner
melts yeah like just suck it up I mean
they start saying crazy stuff like I've
been asking for this for two 20 years
and I can't get it right
um give me one Behavior you want to
change gosh
um let me no let me ask you this before
before that are you what what are you
using now to relieve stress still
pornography from time to time but
getting a a handle on it because I'm I
basically rebuilt my life in the last
two years on my you know just working on
myself doing some leadership stuff
and you know just bettering myself and I
think I'm better to be able to go back
in and help repair my marriage can I
tell you something really hard yeah this
is going to go against all the Bro
Science that we know okay if you are
married you cannot work on yourself in
isolation sure okay sir okay so good for
you man you've done a bunch of stuff but
you haven't done the hard stuff
and you're gonna be like what are you
talking about I started working out I
started listening to Joo podcast I
started doing all this like I started
taking supplements um when you're
married all of your changes impact her
because y'all are one yeah right it's
like the quarterback can't just run out
and be like dude I'm not running those
plays anymore he's got to tell the team
the team has to work together to run
those two
plays yeah because the first few plays
he may actually fool everybody on the
field and get some good gains and after
a while he's going to get himself killed
yeah there's nobody blocking with how I
didn't know how to bring her in no I got
that yeah it's a skill set it's a skill
set and I think you sit down and
uh I recommended this on a couple of
shows ago and it sounds strange and it
sounds so dude I'm gonna get so much
bloody hell for it on the internets and
I just don't
care but there's something about
literally taking a knee in front of your
wife as though you're proposing in to
her and holding both of her
hands and saying I've hidden most of my
life from you for 20 years I'm not
cheating on you I don't have a big
addiction um I do struggle with
pornography
still I have been trying to get
better and but I've been trying to do it
by myself
and you and I breathe the same air we we
we are we are creating something
together and so I can't move unless you
move with
me yeah are you all in and youall have
to figure out what that means for y'all
does that sound scary oh scares the crap
out of me man freaking out is she gonna
leave you no I think being vulnerable
like just feeling like I hate that word
but yeah being vulnerable dude I dude I
hate that word I hate it man God I hate
I don't know what I'm supposed call it
but yeah that's all it is and part of me
getting over my hatred of that word is
by saying it yeah and all vulnerability
means is
this it means that I you can hurt me
with what I'm about to tell you yeah and
what I'm about to tell you is I love you
and I want you I want to be more
connected with you and I don't know how
to do
that and you're gonna
go and she's gonna say like I need you
to have all the answers no I don't know
any wife that says that they're like oh
thank God right um but then it feels
weird coming back but it sounds like
that's the first place to
start and that doesn't mean that you're
not doesn't mean you don't lift weights
that doesn't mean I'm doing something
with Joo like in two weeks doesn't mean
you don't hang I love that guy you don't
not listen to Joo that's not what that
means yeah it means that every morning
you wake up and you say hey honey how
can I love you today okay I've heard you
say that a lot it makes me cringe inside
why okay tell me that because your voice
is important because there's a million
men who listen and go oh God okay
whatever why does that make you cringe I
again it's a place that makes me
vulnerable right is it is it because
you're supposed to know
maybe or is it because that's not even
my freaking job I'm not GNA love her
today I'm going out to kill some and
drag it home and make the money like
what is it I think it's I think it's
because I don't know how to do it I just
don't know how to do it yeah it's yeah
it's not about yeah I'm going to go work
today but um I don't know how to do it
so maybe I'm afraid of failing on that
front again you know Jam
Todd dude that's what dude that's I mean
that's what I was scared of
scared to
death what if my wife says here's what I
need you to love me I need you to help
with bedtime with the kids and I have to
look my wife in the ey and say I don't
know how to do that yeah or my daughter
doesn't want me to read her bedtime
stories and she will scream and kick and
tell me to get
out and I can't handle that I don't know
how to handle
that that was my
house okay yeah like I didn't know how
to do it and the like you the thing that
I love about about you is like what do
you do for a living I'm a nurse yeah
dude how many times you been put in a
situation you got to figure it out cuz
that cat on that table's about to
die and often that's who you
are but in that situation and I'm going
to I'm going to give some Insider
baseball you'll get this Todd but most
people listening who are not in the
emergency response World won't get this
um they train us early on you always
have to bring a calm presence to that
kind of situation when someone's going
to die because um you you bringing chaos
and it it just makes everything worse
and they always tell us at the end of
the day it's their emergency not yours
so bring your peace to the situation
right and so what I'm going to say is
awful and I know but it's it's it's
instructive if you give it your
all with one of your
patients and they don't make
it you're devastated and there's grief
but they're the ones who passed away
yeah in this
situation if you give it your all and
something doesn't work your wife can
look at you and say I don't I reject
that yeah you've hurt me for 20 years
you're using pornography again I'm out
I'm divorcing you just like I told you
10 years
ago yeah right all that can all happen
that's vulnerability she could kill
you but also in my house I lead with I'm
scared to say this out loud my wife says
I hear that
I think that's a good way to start yeah
and I think that's how she'll respond so
she will she will hey I'm I I can't tell
you how proud of you I am oh thank you
what you're embarking on is really
really hard it's a
challenge hang on the line here I'm
going to give you a copy of building a
non-anxious life and um I'll go ahead
and and drop in the thing I'll go ahead
and drop in own your past change your
future building an non- anxious life I
think is going to give you and your wife
a road map an architectural blueprint to
build this new house together and here's
what I think is going to be important
you're a nurse you run hard you save
lives and you're a father and you're a
husband you got all of this stuff that's
pent up and it builds and it builds and
it builds and it builds and you don't
have an offramp for it and what that
means is you've built a very anxious
world then pornography alcohol texting
that woman back at work whatever the
thing is that gives you that release
that Ah that's what kills you
and so if you build something from the
inside out from the floor up that is
non-anxious in in its structure then you
can go in and do crazy hard jobs like
being a nurse like being a fireman like
being a military person like being a
police officer like being a teacher like
being an attorney like being any number
of professions business
owner you can go do really hard things
and Fight Hard bite down on your
mouthpiece and punch and kick hard but
your body never
over does it
doesn't go into anxiousness or Panic
proud of you my brother you're on your
way you're on your way you're asking
great hard
questions take a knee take both your
wife's hands and say I love you I'm
ready to build something new are you
it then Hold On Tight cuz she may just
blow your mind we'll be right
back New Year's is my favorite time of
the year and this year I'm committed to
finally establishing an ongoing
journaling routine developing a
consistent and guided daily prayer
practice as well as getting back to
meditating and doing my coherence
breathing exercises on a daily basis one
place where I can do all of this in the
same location is with my favorite app in
the world hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app on planet Earth it has
over 10,000 audio guided prayers
meditations and music I use the guided
prayers and scripture readings for my
personal development I listen to the LOI
beats while I Journal I'm a sucker for
good lowii and occasionally when things
get sideways I return to the app in the
afternoon for peace throughout the day
whether you're a person of Christian
faith who is looking to renew your way
of living or you're curious about all
this Faith talk and you just want to
explore hallow is for you for listeners
of the Dr John deloney show you get
three free months of hallow all 10,000
plus prayers meditations music the
lecture series and more all of it by
going to hall.com
dealone that's three free months of the
app at hall.com
/one all right let's go out to Vermont
and talk to Jen what's up
Jen well hello what's
up um I don't know what to lead with how
about this start singing your favorite
song and I'll rank you one to 10 on how
good you are yeah let's
not awesome so hey no it's all good I'm
glad that you're here what's up yeah um
okay um typed up some notes yesterday
and they're nowhere near with me so that
that's not even your hey can you me a h
favor I'm uh your your thing's cutting
in and out oh that's terrible I'm sorry
is that better keep talking okay so
anyway I don't know if I should lead
with thinking back on it I'm third
generation of not good marriage and I
want to stop that so my daughter's got a
good chance or should I lead with that
my yeah a husband's grumpiness is kind
of becoming his status quo and when he
becomes happy I don't even know what to
do with that or should I lead
with we've been married 12 years
and if we've been physically intimate
five times I'd be
surprised yeah let's go with option
C
okay um that will get the most YouTube
clips um actually the uh clicks the
um I'm really interested in your second
question um let's let's loot back there
because I already have a sense but I'm
just guessing um I'm just I'll just be
fishing in the dark but that's a
fascinating question you just asked um
so y'all been married 12 years You' have
had sex five times you think well
probably yes I mean I'm not really
exaggerating one way or the other with
that
why listen counseling 101 never ask why
questions um so thankfully we're not
doing therapy like why like what what's
happened over a decade that either of
y'all have put up with
that
um oh my goodness I don't even it
um it depends on who you talk to
I'm only talking to Jen I understand
that's true okay so for me it was
um it turned
into lack
of lack of trust in the fact that lack
of support lack of I don't feel like
this is a partnership in any way shape
or form um I was definitely feeling like
a single mom I was hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on hold
on
does he want to sleep with you and you
just
won't or has he had no interest in you
for 12
years well right now there's really no
interest yeah it's I mean it's 12 years
he's so mad okay that um but there there
was he had a like when you'all got most
people have I'm say most people when we
first first got married no the I was
like are we going to like I believe the
technical term is consummate uhhuh and
like 6 months into the marriage we went
back to a marriage counselor that we had
seen when we were engaged and my
question was we haven't had sex
yet so I was the one pushing them Jen I
am rarely speechless and you just got me
you got me it's a little nutty wow I
mean I say nutty but it it's very very
very
abnormal
but so my question to you is six months
is a really long
time for some six hours six minutes is a
really long time like what were the
conversations
like
um they really
weren't I'm it's it's the weirdest yeah
and it's shocking to me because we're
both I don't want to do we're both smart
people it's nothing to do intelligence
yeah has nothing to do that we have were
morons when it comes to any of this
okay's and and I'll be straight up
um 15 minutes
ago my husband was just sitting at my
desk just anyway trying to get a self
anyway and he was at my desk and he saw
my d planner open and he was on hold and
he goes hey what's that and I was on
hold for you uhhuh and in it I had
written you know this appointment in my
day planner had to he's like what's that
and he goes you're not doing that are
you and I'm like well yeah I'm going to
and he was like
what and I was my whole thing was I'm
like
because I'll at
straws I lost what you just said what'
you say ma'am I said I'll just grasp it
anything not to like be little what you
do no no trust me it's it's definitely
you were at you were scraping the bottom
of the barrel here here's um here's
what's it feels like okay yes
sir
um it feels like one of a couple of
things there is way way way more to the
story and when I say that I mean like
abuse like some severe trauma responses
some very significant not emotional
distress but mental health disorders
there's something else going on here
that's number one number
two
um and by the way you and I just are
meeting I'm very very direct okay
because in most of that is because I
have I I love you and most of that is
because I've got a very compressed time
right so it's only 10 minutes right um
it sounds like for 10 or 12 years you've
been stepping over $1,000 checks and
$100 bills to pick up
pennies like we're grasping grasping at
straws here but we haven't sat down and
asked our husband
like I want to have sex with you can we
can we try
this I feel distant from you can we plug
in I feel like a single mom can we
connect
here and instead of entering into that
conversation that admittedly may go
awful may end up in US
separating instead of us but it may also
end up in US fixing
everything instead of that we wait six
months and then we just call a
professional it's like a tiny little
fire getting lit in in the in the actual
fireplace but we just don't deal with it
we just don't deal with it and 6 months
later the whole House's on fire now we
got to call the fire
department right and
so I guess Circle back how I mean I
can't unwind this in a in a in a one
small segment how can I help you right
now like what are you aiming for what's
your goal
here my goal would be I really like when
you mentioned to parents where they're
like e my relationship with my kids I
don't know and whatever age if they're
still at home they're like get a
notebook have the kid write something
you write something have the kid and I'm
like what a
basic it's basic that works that
builds I guess I'm
just you you I only tell parents to do
that with kids because kids don't have
the intellectual plus the emotional
ability to articulate in a conversation
right adults should have
that and so if you're unable to if you
and your husband are unable to sit
across the table and say
dude we have been living a farce for 12
years cuz you calling and saying I'm
frustrated my husband's
grumpy that's like that's what we call
it right yeah but I mean that's like
your house burning down to the ground
and you calling 911 cuz it's hot
outside that's not the issue
here you saying hey I am committed to
being the one who breaks the cycle of
bad
marriages and out of the
gate six months and I say intimacy I'm
not talking about
intercourse intimacy being able to just
talk about it with each
other
and so instantly the recipe for a
marriage that's dysfunctional or that's
not working for either of you that
creates a home that's full of tension
and Chaos repeats itself
again and that's not on you that's on
that's on the whole
system you see what I'm saying
yeah
completely I've been working with a
killer therapist okay
for nine months now okay awesome for me
yes it was just me oneon-one
um from my perspective I'm radically
Different awesome the people that are
really close to me um some
co-workers they can totally tell a
difference they said I'm like okay
that's
cool
um my husband obviously not really
it that's not surprising to me me
because just one change yeah well as
Esther Perell tells us she y'all are in
the dance y'all haven't address the
dance right like yall have a rhythm and
a routine in fact you don't even know
what to do with him when he's not grumpy
and so the incentive inside his own home
is to be
grumpy it's like you don't even know
what to say to him when he starts
speaking to you in Italian you just want
him to speak Spanish because that's the
language you know that's the language
your kid knows that's the language the
house that damic
nose and so even when he Peaks his head
out and and there's
joy it's not met with any sort of
reciprocal Joy it's met with who who is
this and he's like completely and he
goes back to Grump right so there's this
Dynamic set up in your
home right and the only way that gets
busted is somebody you've heard me say
this someone's got to turn the lights on
turn the music off stop
dancing and what does that mean in real
life life that's that's a big metaphor
people ask me like what does that
actually mean that means you getting a
babysitter for your child your kids and
you sitting across the table from your
husband and saying we haven't had sex in
years you don't like being around me and
I don't even know how to interact with
you when you're
grumpy I want a different kind of
marriage are you in to build something
completely new
based on Grace and forgiveness and
trying new things moving forward because
what we've been doing does not
work anything short of that you're going
to go to therapy you're going to become
this amazing new person on the inside
you're going to walk back into your
house right back into the same costume
that you always wear until one of you
either has the courage to call
it or one of the other one does
something just so dumb cheats on
somebody steals something from somebody
does something awful that then everybody
can go look what they did um or your
child starts acting out to try to get
somebody's attention to say please can
we cut the tension on this home because
I can't
breathe often the way the way I phrase
this is you have to choose your heart
there's not an easy path out of
this right it's either going to end in a
in a in a
supernova or it's going to end in a
whimper and an
ash or it's going to be something built
completely new it's going to be amazing
why are you so avoidant of that
conversation is he abusing
you no there's a lot of
um everything is said you're trying to
accuse me of stuff here you come you're
blaming me again for everything
you're it all is and I'm like I'm not
blaming you I want to just can we just
have a normal conversation can we like
actually write things on paper can we
together
do I brought some of the suggestions
that my therapist has said some of the
things that I've heard on your show and
um and
it's it turns into basically another
argument another full shutdown
another like five six days of no
communication so behavior is a language
what's he telling
you
that I'll give you his language he does
not want to be married to
you that's what his Lang that's what his
behavior is telling
you
tell me I'm wrong I love being
wrong I'd like
to but that's been the language
since we were
dating
okay until you choose to live in that
reality you're going to continue Chasing
Ghosts it's going to be exhausting
here's the other thing you may be
wrong there's been a couple of times in
my marriage over 21 years 21 and a half
years when wife I when he's been in his
happy mood or we can actually have a
conversation he looks at me and he's
even like you know for him shed tears a
few times while seeing it and he says
that
he Saidi am married to
you because for any reason whether it
was a good reason or a bad reason I
believe God brought us together and I
believe that I on purpose chose you to
be my
wife he has said that probably three
times three or four times in the last
year and a half
and I'm like so do I believe that it it
doesn't matter what he
says what if I just walked down the
street Jen announcing to the world how
in shape I
am right doesn't
matter God wants me to be in shape and I
chose this
gy and I just announced that God called
me to be ripped and I chose this gym do
you ever go in that gym and work out
no right I'm not talking to you for six
days for even asking that question you
bastard like what like what are you I
don't care what he says so what's the
conversation that I have then I'll tell
you the I was I tell you the one I had
in my house I've had it twice maybe
three times maybe four times over 21
years it is two adults sitting across
the table and I think I I don't remember
how I preface it I don't like to think
of the specifics but um when need have a
very direct grown-up hard conversation
that's going to be very emotional and I
just want us both to prep for
it and it goes something like this
marriage as it currently is cannot
contain you I do not feel in my body
that you want to be married to me
anymore um if you do I've got some real
challenges because I'm not I'm not
feeling it I'm not accepting it and I'm
not not being a good partner to you we
got to do something completely new are
you
in and every time the other person has
said absolutely
Allin but somebody has to sit at a
grown-up table and even if you have to
call out every time we have a hard
conversation you don't talk to me for
six days you shut down you say oh what
about me we're not doing any of that
today this is two grown-ups having a
grown-up
conversation
are we going to stay
married and here's what you have to have
already
prepared I need moving forward not you
haven't done this and you haven't done
that that's not it cannot work that way
because if you come at him that way he
has to defend himself and his defense
strategy is to shut down and become a
joy vacuum in his own house right
right and so the only way forward is for
you to say I
need physical and sexual intimacy in my
at
home I need to be able to have
conversations good bad scary vulnerable
hilarious
silly I got to be able to share my life
with my
partner and on whatever the things you
need I don't and I don't know what that
is I don't know what that is for you but
you're GNA have to be able to say those
things out loud and this is
hard but I think you be very clear if
you get up and walk away from the table
I will understand that you want this
marriage to be
over if you don't talk to me for five
days after this discussion I understand
you are not interested in in changing
the way this relationship
works if you're going to sit at this
table and we're going to we're going to
figure this thing out then I recognize
that you're all
in going backwards over the last 12
years my gut tells me if I was talking
to him there would be enough blame to go
around maybe not maybe I'm maybe you're
protecting him and whatever maybe he's
got some major psychological challenges
that you have just had to dance around
for 12 years
maybe but going back and blaming is not
going to help anybody there's going to
be an important forensic accounting of
the last 12 years hey this is how you've
dealt with conflict I can't have that
moving forward you got to be present
with me give me some tools so I can when
I ever I need to bring something up to
you it won't doesn't shut you down
because just shutting down doesn't solve
our
problem we're going to have to put sex
on a calendar we're going to have to put
weekly meetings on a calendar we're
going to have to have a budget together
we're going to have to have parenting
conversations we're going to have to be
married I'm sorry Jen I wish I had more
for
you I wish I could just pass this one
and be like ah here it is this one's
tough this one's tough this one's
tough
somebody's got to flip the lights on
someone's got to turn the music off and
stop the dance and just say hey this is
the state of our marriage we're choosing
reality it's the state of our
marriage I'm going forward no more we
got to be different starting now are you
in let me know how it goes Jen we'll be
thinking about you we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone some people think
relationships are going to be easy easy
if they're going to be right that's
almost never true great relationships
get that way because both people put in
the work to make them great and therapy
can be a place to work through the
challenges you face in all of your
relationships whether with friends
people at work your romantic partner or
even how you get along with yourself so
if you're thinking about starting
therapy I want you to try better help
cuz therapy isn't just for people who've
experienced trauma it's it's great for
building skills so you can be the best
version of yourself so you can show up
in those relationships and do your part
to make the relationship great better
help is completely online so it's
flexible enough to fit your schedule
just fill out a short questionnaire to
get match with a licensed therapist and
you can switch therapist at any time for
no extra cost find the PATH forward to
make all of your relationships
incredible visit betterhelp.com dealone
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
delone all right let's go up to
Vancouver and talk to Amanda what's up
Amanda nothing much how are you good
what are you
doing nothing awesome is this super
weird you're just having a regular day
and then all a sudden
ah yeah pretty much superbly awkward so
yeah I've been told I'm awkward my whole
life so it's all good good to meet you
what's
up um basically I guess sort of my
question is um every holiday my mother
literally and my grandmother will
literally crying um for literally hours
uh every time I tell them that I won't
be attending the family events uh
including my father's side um I'm half
flatten so that's kind of really um
offensive to them but says did you say
you're half did you say you're half
you're half
Latin yes got very ctin colors calling
on to the show and it's like very
cultural AB at the same time it's just
too much yes and I can't handle going to
some of the events um most of the time
anymore so I just uh have a hard time
every single holiday or birthday or
whatever else they think is important
basically um
why yeah I'll just kind of cut to the
chase is that okay cuz I I I totally get
this I'll try too but I it's very hard
no I got
it do
um why do you subject yourself to hours
of their tears and wailing and nashing
of
teeth um I guess I just think that like
I wish I did I wish I could go I guess
in a way and I I feel like u i kind of
buy into their guilt over it but at the
same time yeah I guess I wish what
happened didn't happen and I wish I
could go I want to offer an alternative
explanation okay I think you subject
yourself to punishment because you feel
like you should go and this is what you
get for not
going okay and I don't I want you to
know you're off the hook for that what
happened in your family that makes
attending a
nogo it's what's hard is it's not about
all my random relatives it's really
between me and uh one of my siblings or
my only sibling um yeah basically when I
was very young they told me her and her
husband told me that they didn't want me
around because I was kind of like taking
up too much of their Spotlight um on
both sides of the family so what this is
something I still deal with today it's
been 13 years and I still I'm still very
old to still be dealing with that but
well no that hurts but um I mean it's
clearly insane and ludicrous my question
to you is um what about you is so small
that you let them continue to run your
life don't
know like why wouldn't you go and let
your Amanda light shine all over the
family and if they want to opt out
they're welcome
to yeah that's true I mean I wish I
would have done different things when I
was way younger when it happened but um
yeah but we're here now so why not now
exactly yeah um I think just everything
that they hear that I do they go and do
and it just kind of like puts more of a
what pump in it for me like I don't
understand give me an example okay yeah
I'll give you an example so one day like
I decided to go on a hike on a specific
Mountain um it's Vancouver area so and
then like the next months they went and
did the same hike or U one time I got I
had a boyfriend and people really liked
him and then um basically I got cheated
on with my sibling um with that person
um your sister went hooked up with ended
up buying a farm and then they bought a
bigger farm and she bought a bigger F
like that kind of thing so it's just
very you should get a huge fake face
tattoo that would be amazing if you got
like a huge rose on your cheek and been
like what's up and just see if they
actually get do it for real that'd be
amazing that' be
awesome yeah or you should just rent
like a you should rent a Ferrari and be
like look at my new ride
yeah to see how far they'll take it
here's the
thing and I say this with all due
respect who cares what they
do
okay I'm asking you that I'm not just
saying putting that unto the
world because when you when you take
them out when you take them off the
table you're doing amazing things you
bought a farm you got a boyfriend your
sister sucks for cheating on him uh
cheating with him on you or what however
you say that uhuh but like okay you're
going out doing
life Sor maybe you're doing it so well
you're the ultimate family influencer
and they're like yeah that would be
amazing too or maybe you just have a
sister with a
significant psychiatric Challenge and
it's just she's gonna keep doing what
she does that's her
life okay okay is that fair that makes
sense yeah oh
yeah taking notes so hopefully that
helps I don't know but I mean here's the
thing if your mom and your mom has a
picture where all of her daughters all
get together perfectly and everybody
does everything perfect and everything
looks perfect and everything's perfect
right yes yes and so anytime there's a
fight in the family it's always oh my
gosh what about me and and then Mom
cries and then you're supposed to all
make it better your sister's not going
to make it better cuz she's freaking
amazing and so it's your job to make it
better and you just said forget all this
right pretty much there's a third
option which is I love my mom I love my
family I like the big messy Latin
holiday parties I've been to a few a
grou of Texas they're my favorite on the
planet they're amazing and you know they
are they're incredible yeah yeah and I'm
not going to let a grumpy neurotic
sister over in the corner keep me from
here okay she can go buy what she wants
to buy she can whisper in my ear you're
taking my sping all right dude I'm going
to continue to laugh and dance and eat
and have fun and love my mom and is my
mom a little
bit yes she is okay does my mom cry a
lot yes she does it's my
mom but if you look around I can hear it
in your story so many things about your
life brought you
Joy one person
squashed a little bit of it and cast a
shadow over everything you love and care
about okay is that fair tell me I'm
wrong I might be completely
wrong uh yeah that's close enough to it
yeah I always try to do something or try
to get over something and yeah this
feels like this is like an overarching
story line that I'm kind of tired of um
your sister's not going to change is she
no no it's yeah your mom's not GNA
change is
she no no not at all
okay so my question for you is long term
what's going to bring you the most peace
and the most
Joy is it staying at home and saying Mom
it's not my job to make you happy it's
not my job to make you fulfilled and you
have this fantasy of all of your
daughters getting together my sister is
a train wreck and I'm not doing it
anymore you've picked her over me fine
I'm just going to stay at home and have
peace sem my home here in
Vancouver or is it kids hop in the wagon
we're going to the Grandma's house for
the
holidays and it is going to be unhinged
and we're going to sing we're going to
dance we're going to play we're going to
have fun and tial Loa over here in the
corner is just gonna do her
thing uhhuh
right yeah okay but you get to pick here
here's what I'm trying to get you to see
you're in the dve driver seat of your
own
life okay and you don't have a path
forward that doesn't come with some sort
of relational
discomfort okay there's no there's not
an easy path out is that
fair right yeah that makes sense I'm
writing that down
okay and so just because it hurts
doesn't mean it's not right and it might
hurt when your older sister or younger
sister like tries to photocopy your life
or is always one upping
you
um it just a lot so I just don't know
how to even do boundaries really but I
guess those are two good options and
probably reality will probably be
somewhere in the middle I'm not sure
well it's gonna be uncomfortable and
you're gonna feel some guilt over the
last 13 years you're gonna have to let
that go okay because that's not going to
solve you right
now okay you're going to have to say hey
I've made some choices over the last 13
years years that have brought me here
kept me safe kept me sane helped me
raise my family here we are great I'm
making different choices Life's too
short I'm gonna go be with my family
over the holidays and I've got
one um sister who's just just gonna do
it sister gonna
do and I'll minimize my contact there I
will minimize my kids contact there but
we're family and we're just going to
show
up okay and I would I'm a little
bit I'm the guy that I picked my sister
upal makes sense I know I know I know
but listen I picked my sister up at the
airport this year for the holidays with
a huge sign that
said well thank God my sister's finally
gone ARA free and my little daughter had
a sign that said welcome home from
jail and it was
hilarious and then my sister called one
of my favorite drummers in all of my
life from the band Poison one of my 80s
metal band and did a cameo and he called
me sent me a message that said
congratulations on kicking that chyia I
mean that's my brother that's our sister
back and forth that's us
okay it's unhinged it's weird it's silly
it's funny it's just how we interact and
also love her to death and I know she
loves me
too okay but it comes with some ups and
some downs and some sideways that's just
that's s the nature of it okay but
here's what I'm telling you I want you
to feel fully empowered
to reverse engineer your
life I want my holidays to feel full of
laughter and
warmth and
family what has to be true for those
things to happen sometimes for those
things to be true we can't go visit
extended family it's too violent it's
too volatile we have we have people
there that make it uncomfortable because
they're ugly or they're rude
sometimes it's we're going to go do
those things and I'm going to set some
really firm boundaries about when we go
to bed what kids are going to watch or
not eat or if anyone tells these jokes
we're
out or sometimes it's really clear
boundaries with inside my family hey um
sister so and so Aunt so and so she says
things that aren't true she Whispers
mean things we're just going to we're
just going to smile and we're going to
ignore we're going to move on because
the end result is warmth and
connectivity in
family so get with with your husband and
y'all sit down and ask this question
what do we want the holidays to feel
like my guess is based on this call it's
going to include your mom and maybe even
your
grandma and that means it's also
probably going to include sister so what
do we got to
do or if once and for all I'm not doing
it no more with sister okay it's going
to come at the cost and then I'm going
to stop listening to my mom cry for two
hours I'm going to tell my mom I'm going
to hang up the phone I'm going to send
an email note to everybody my mom calls
sobbing I will tell her I love her mom I
can't be in the presence of my older
sister and I know that hurts but I've
got to take care of me and my family I
will call you back and if Mom's going to
sit there and blame and yell and cry
then I'm going to say Mom I'm hanging up
now I'm going let you go and then we'll
reconvene you get back in the driver
seat of your own
life and don't let one naysayer
one one Dark Soul cast a shadow over
your whole life you've got too much to
live life's too fun there's too much
Adventure out
there to let one weirdo take it all from
you thanks for the call Amanda
appreciate you coming in clutch we'll be
right
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at john.com
all right as we wrap up today's show one
of my
favorite rock and roll metal bands of
all
time Slaughter and and it's Mark
Slaughter is a resident here in town one
of my favorite singers ever ever ever
and somebody who Kelly still may or may
not have pictures of him on her screen
saver and on her
desk might wearing a vest and not a lot
else uh Kelly loves the mark Slaughter I
do one of the up all night sleep all day
fly of the Angels my gosh and probably
one of the best voices ever ever in that
especially in that genre of music we
listen to and by far the best
smile Swoon she's being so gross right
now like her like her whole body's lit
up like a light bulb it's giving me the
but and he's in town you can Kelly can
feel his presence when she's driving on
I know I've actually been to a couple of
events that he's been at and um one of
the guys that works here Greg James is
run into him a couple times at like
Lowe's yeah so I've been hanging out at
Lowe's but it hadn't happened
oh
jeez oh man the
[Laughter]
song's ironically the song's called
desperately which is uh an Ode to Kelly
and her just need to see Mark Slaughter
in person you never say hi what's on
your mind oh she does just tell me honey
lay it on the line anytime night or day
just call me up and I'll be on my way
the clock strikes midnight I don't know
where you are the clock strikes strikes
it's all right just tell me honey don't
push me too
far desperately I got to know my name is
Kelly Mark call me if you love me so I
added that last line Kelly uh I think
you and I go get tattoos and you're
going to fit Slaughter in it's going to
be
amazing who says that I our we have
it I'll leave you with that thought
America love you guys
[Music]
bye